I'm Ron I'm Brian and we're here to talk
to you about national Geographics first
scripted show ingenious we're focusing
on Albert Einstein ten episodes that
encompasses an entire life
we as contemporary people in this
contemporary civilization we're living
in we know of the icon Albert Einstein
but we don't really think he failed a
thing when I was your age I knew
everything but I was wrong and as we're
all coping and trying to survive and
trying to aspire to something we are
failing in things often if you're taking
any risk and you get to see that's what
he did because you'll be so jealous with
my life this is all about human
insurance is about getting underneath
how the genius work what did and didn't
allow or nearly prevent the genius to
emerge they're not caught dominated the
story itself is propelled by a mystery
and I think that people would just
access into it and then find all these
other dimension and this is what we
found
going back to Apollo 13 or A Beautiful
Mind and many other movies where we made
a study out of complex parentage is that
the more detail the better audiences are
far smarter and far more fascinated by
really detailed thoughtful elements a
story
and we probably realized when we began
our careers and this is one of the
things we've discovered and trying to
apply it to Albert Einstein
[Music]
you